大家好,我是Jim,這裡是AI Notebook,這一集是演講訪談系列。
主角是Leonardo de Mora,他是Lean的創造者,現在是Lean FRO的首席架構師。
今年7月25號,網路上出現一份證明,說他推翻了一個放了將近90年的數學猜想,叫Caulatz猜想。
這份證明附上了Lean的檢查結果,Lean蓋了章。
另一套獨立寫成的檢查程式,也蓋了章。
可是這份證明是錯的,Caulatz猜想到今天,沒有人證明,也沒有人推翻。
頻道前一支影片我們講
OpenAI公開700多篇AI數學論文
那支片的結論之一是
附上LIN證明的成果
比較讓人放心
這一集要往下多問一層
聯邦數學證明
蓋章的程式都可能被騙
AI大量交出證明以後
我們到底能相信什麼
這一集就只問這個問題
我們分三步看
先看蓋章的程式是怎麼被騙的
再看就算章是真的
那到底保證了什麼
最後看
當證明長到沒有人讀得完
還剩下什麼工作
先講LIN是什麼
LIN是一種程式語言
也許他會檢查每一步合不合規則
全部通過
他才承認這個證明成立
這類軟體有個正式名字叫證明輔助程式
你可以把它想成數學的裁判
數學家在紙上寫證明
靠的是同行一頁一頁讀
另不看感覺只看規則
哪一步跳太快他就吹哨
把紙上的證明翻成另看得懂的寫法
叫形式化
就像把食譜上的鹽少許
寫成鹽三克
每一步都不能考一會
De Mora從十幾年前開始寫另
他原本以為
這會是工程師用來檢查重要系統的工具
沒想到後來陶哲軒這樣的數學家也用他
還到處演講介紹
到了AI會寫證明的今天
很多研究團隊都拿Lin來檢查AI寫的證明
因為他的判決不靠人的眼睛
可是裁判本身也是程式
程式就會有bug
也就是寫錯的地方
Lin整套系統非常龐大
裡面有自動找證明的工具
有各種方便的寫法
現在還有AI在旁邊幫忙寫
這麼大的東西怎麼可能沒有錯
Lin的回答是一個叫核心的設計
英文叫Kernel
核心是Lin裡面一小段程式
只有幾千行
負責最後一道檢查
前面不管是人寫的
工具產生的
還是AI寫的
最後都要交給核心
一步一步重新核對一次
所以核心就像裁判手上那本規則書
比賽現場再亂
球員的花招再多
只要最後的判決
照規則書來
結果就算數
你不用相信整個Ling
只要相信這本薄薄的規則書
這個想法叫做
小而可信的核心
它是整支影片的地基
後面每個故事
都是在問這本規則書
靠不靠得住
聽他自己說
先認識扣卡斯猜想
它的規則很簡單
隨便選一個正整數
如果是偶數
就變成它的一半
如果是奇數就乘以3再加1
然後一直重複下去
比如從3開始
會變成10
再變成5
最後落回1
數字忽上忽下
像冰雹在雲裡翻滾
所以它也叫冰雹疏裂
猜想說的是
不管從哪個數字開始
最後都會落回1
電腦已經檢查到
天文數字那麼大都成立
可是將近90年來
沒有人證明它
7月25號
Romanakuma在Github
一個放程式碼的網站上
公開一份Lin證明
宣稱證明瞭
這個猜想是錯的
這份證明是AI協助產生
Lin的官方核心接受了它
Lin還回報
這份證明沒有偷用
任何額外的假設
另一個獨立寫成的核心叫Nanoda也接受了
兩位裁判同時放行了一份站不住的證明
聽他自己說
事後調查發現
兩位裁判是被兩個不同的漏洞騙過的
先講官方核心
零裡有一種資料性別
像是盒子裡又包著另一個盒子
核心在處理這種東西的時候
漏了一道檢查
有一部分內容
從頭到尾沒有被看過
只要在那個沒人看的位置
放一個錯的東西
就能讓核心接受一個命題
叫false
也就是假
核心一旦承認假是真的
什麼都證得出來
連0等於1都可以
就像裁判被騙
在一張空白單子上蓋了張
之後拿張單子
想寫什麼就寫什麼
Demo啊
特別強調
這是陳詩寫錯
不是令背後的數學理論有動
而且這個漏洞要繞過平常的寫法
直接把東西塞給核心才碰得到
另一位裁判南諾達
是Chris Bailey用Ross這種程式語言
從頭寫的另一個核心
官方漏掉的那一處
他有檢查
卻漏了另一處
他從一個東西里取出某一欄的時候
沒有確認
這個東西真的是他自稱的那種結構
就像檢票員只看座位號碼
沒看這張票是不是這班車的
這份證明的厲害之處
是兩個洞剛好對得上
官方沒檢查的那段
正好放進舊版的Noda會放行的東西
等Moradai修補官方核心的時候
注意到證明裡有一段
跟數學毫無關係的東西
被製造雜臭碰撞
雜臭是程式T一大段資料
算出的一串短短的編號
像指紋
碰撞
就是兩個不一樣的東西
算出同一個指紋
聽他自己說
I said why did they put this stuff there
is to pass NANOTA
I mean to exploit the bug in NANOTA
7月28號
研究員Kieran Gopinathan
把這份證明說成一小段誠實
用最短的寫法讓Lin證出假
然後回報給Lin團隊
修正是Dimora本人寫的
從回報到他交出修正
只用了幾個小時
Lin團隊的Joaquin Breitner審過
提出改進
當天就合並進去
至於NANOTA差不多同一時間
他也剛被回報修補了一個漏洞
而這份證明用的正是修補前的舊版
這麼巧
是不是AI讀到了Nanoda的修補記錄
才設計出這個攻擊
提出這份證明的Romana認為是巧合
但也不能排除模型讀過那份回報
Liyin團隊另一個看法是
時間撞在一起
是因為現在剛好有夠強的模型
找得到這種漏洞了
這段訪談錄在7月底
就是事情發生的那一週
影片9月底才上架
Dimora在訪談裡說了一句後來應驗的話
聽他怎麼講
what we can do to improve
Because this is going to keep happening
people's AI is really good
Bugs in the kernels
他說對了而且來得很快
訪談錄完沒幾天
從7月30號到8月20號
OpenAI的研究員Denny Selsom
用公司內部的模型
對
另的核心和執行環境
辦了一場抓漏洞大賽
一直進行到模型回報
找不到更多了
結果模型又找出好幾個漏洞
每一個都能讓官方核心接受甲
大部分被Nanoda和一個新寫的檢查程式擋了下來
但有一個連舊版Nanoda也放行了
Dimora在事後報告裡說其中兩招非常巧妙
一招跟技術器有關
程式會記住某個東西正被幾個地方使用
這個數字叫參照技術
模型故意讓這個技術器異位
就像汽車的里程錶轉過頭歸零
把記憶體弄亂再趁亂正出甲
另一招是發現Lean在Linux上的官方版本
用了一個舊版的大數運算函式庫
叫GMP Linux
是一種常見的作業系統
GMP專門處理很大的數字
這個舊版有已知的bug
模型就拿它來造假證明
8月21號
另釋出新版
把這些漏洞全部修補好
還加了一個指令
可以一次用所有內建的核心
把證明重新檢查一遍
同一段時間
用公開模型找漏洞的團隊
沒有人回報任何一個
報告裡還有一句很重的話
我們把AI產生的證明
當成可能的惡意證明
那要怎麼防
DEMORA的方向
不是把一位裁判變得更強
而是請更多位彼此獨立的裁判
不同的人
用不同的程式語言
各自從頭寫一個核心
同一份證明交給每一位都檢查一次
一個人寫出的漏洞
另一個人剛好犯同一個錯的機會
小的多
另一團隊用來重新檢查證明的工具
叫Comparator
他想把考卷收走
換一間教室
請兩位老師重新批改事件之後
Comparator預設
會同時用官方核心和Nanodart檢查
而且每天換上最新版的Nanodart
再往下一層是
證明核心本身沒有寫錯
Mario Canero在做一個叫Linfo-Lin的專案
用另來證明另的核心是對的
可是他還沒證完
偏偏沒證到的
就是這次被攻擊的那一塊
而且他照著官方核心寫
連同一個漏洞也一起抄了過去
Demora說
要是那部分先證完
這個漏洞會在被利用之前就被找到
他也反對把核心藏起來
靠保密換安全
他認核心必須公開
大家才能一起檢查
就算核心證明是對的
他要靠編譯器
也就是把程式翻成電腦指令的工具
最後在處理器上執行
每一層都可能出錯
所以這條路要一路往下走
聽他自己說
先收下第一部分的答案
蓋章的程式被騙了我們還能相信什麼
答案是
不要只相信一位裁判
把必須信任的東西說到最小
只剩一本薄薄的規則書
再請好幾位彼此獨立的裁判
各自拿自己的規則書核對
規則書本身要公開給所有人檢查
最好還能被證明沒有寫錯
另一團隊現在的態度
是把AI交來的每一份證明
都當成可能是來找漏洞的
這樣做以後
章蓋下去就可信得多
可是還有一個問題沒回答
就算每一位裁判都沒被騙
這個章到底保證了什麼
接下來的主角
是一個你每天都在用
卻大概沒看過的程式
這個程式叫Zlib
它是一套把資料壓小的程式庫
你下載檔案
打開網頁
看一張PNG圖片
背後常常都有它在幫忙
它是幾十年前用C這種程式語言寫的
大量的軟體都靠它
今年2月
Mora公開了
Lean團隊的Kim Morrison做的一個實驗
Kim用的是Cloud
一個一般用途的AI
沒有為了證明數學特別訓練過
拿來直接用
請他把Zlib翻成Lean
再用Lean證明它是對的
裡莫瓦說
年初他覺得這件事
沒指望AI還不夠好
這裡要先分清楚兩個詞
測試是拿一些例子去試
例子都對
不代表所有情況都對
證明
對
所有可能的輸入都成立
差別就像煮一鍋湯
試吃十口都不鹹
跟保證整鍋每一口都不鹹
是兩回事
結果AI不只做到測試
還做到了證明
聽他自己說
with the C version
and then it proves that
for any compression level
for any data
if you compress the data
and then decompress
you get the original data back
他證明的那句話是
不管哪一種壓縮等級
不管什麼資料
壓縮再解壓縮
都拿回原本那一份
這是對所有資料成立的保證
不是試試幾口
這一句被證明成立的話叫定理
接著Kim讓AI放手去讓程式變快
條件只有一個
每修改一次
都要重新證明那個定理
震不出來就不準合併進去
這種做法
Lean團隊說是把正名當成極輪
極輪是隻能往一個方向轉的齒輪
腳踏車後輪裡就有
往前踩會帶著車子走
往後倒踩就空轉
這裡的意思是
城市只能往更快的方向走
不能一邊變快一邊變錯
結果在同樣的壓縮程度下
它的壓縮速度
贏過一個很常用的Rust壓縮函式庫
叫Minis Oxide
Rust是一種以又快又安全出名的語言
不過要講清楚
它不是比所有版本都快
更講究速度的Z-Lib NG和Z-Lib RS
大部分情況還是比他快
DeMura的感想是
人沒有耐心做這種
很低階很瑣碎的最佳化
AI有
他說去年他還覺得不可能
現在看得到一條路了
他還說了一句很有把握的話
聽他怎麼講
作弊不了
這句話有個前提
就是裁判本身沒有漏洞
第一部分我們才看過
這個前提不見得成立
而且就算裁判沒被騙
還要問一件事
章蓋在哪一句話上
那一句話叫規格
英文叫specification
規格是寫清楚一個程式
應該做到什麼的那段敘述
證明保證的是程式符合這段規格
規格沒寫的是證明不負責
這就像蓋房子的合約
驗收的人只對照合約
合約裡沒寫的
就不在保證範圍
Zlib剛好可以看到這件事
今年2月那一版的定理
有一個小小的前提資料要小於1GB
這個上限
是AI為了把證明收尾
自己加上去的
後來的版本換了寫法
但你看
合約上的一行小字
就決定了保證的範圍
今年4月
Kieran Gopinathan
就是後來回報
Coloss漏洞的那一位
用Cloud帶著一組自動化工具
對這個Lin版的Zlib
做了1億零500萬次模糊測試
模糊測試
就是不停丟亂七八糟的資料進去
看程式會不會出事
結果很有意思
被證明過的那部分
另程式碼
一個記憶體漏洞都沒有
可是他在另一的執行環境裡
找到一個記憶體溢出的漏洞
影響所有版本
執行環境
是讓另一程式真正在
電腦上運作的那層底座
記憶體溢出
就是往一個格子塞進超過容量的資料
蓋到隔壁的格子
他還在Zlib裡一段沒有被證明的程式
找到一個能讓程式癱瘓的漏洞
來短程式
負責讀壓縮檔的目錄
證明守住了他承諾的那一塊
出事的地方
都在合約外面
我再收下這部分的答案
就算裁判都沒被騙人章保證的
也只是寫下來的那句規格
而且只涵蓋被證明的那一塊
規格寫窄了
藏了一行小字
或者有一段程式根本沒被證明
章都管不到
把前面兩部分接起來
我們能相信的東西就很清楚了
一個是那幾位彼此獨立的裁判
另一個是你寫下來的規格
其他的
像執行環境編譯器處理器
都要一層一層在檢查
這聽起來很麻煩
為什麼不乾脆找人組行讀一遍
因為有些證明
已經長到沒有人讀得完
回到頻道前一支影片
OpenAI用內部的模型
推翻了數學家
艾迪區提出的一個猜想
叫單位距離猜想
講的是平面上一堆點之間
最多能有多少對點
剛好距離相同
艾迪區是20世紀
發表最多論文的數學家之一
這個推翻的結果
有一份令
證明
由Boris Alexiev公開出來
迪莫拉在訪談裡
就拿他當例子
他的主張是
就算有一個模型
幾乎每一次都答對
我們還是要一張證書
這裡的證書
指的是一份機器人檢查的證明
他不靠你相信誰
任何人都能拿任何一位裁判
重新核對一遍
這就是第一部分那些裁判的用處
證書不是給人讀的
是給裁判讀的
至於那份令證明有多長
聽他自己說
一行讀十秒
一天讀八個小時
一個人要讀一年多
沒有人會這樣讀
也不必這樣讀
只要第一部分的那幾位裁判都點頭
張證書就算數
這就是第三部分的答案
證明多到人讀不完的時候
我們不再主行讀證明
而是相信兩樣東西
好幾位彼此獨立
而且公開給大家檢查了裁判
以及我們自己寫下來的規格
所以人的工作
搬到了最前面
林木娜的看法是
AI很擅長把文獻裡現成的招數組合起來
可是需要發揮的方式
發明新招的時候他好像還差一截
更根本的是
什麼才是我們要的
只有我們說得出來
規格寫錯了
證明在完美
也只是完美D證明瞭一件錯的事
這也是他對人類角色的回答
聽他自己說
我們回到開場那個問題
聯邦數學證明蓋章的程式都可能被騙
AI大量交出證明以後
我們到底能相信什麼
DMUA的答案有三層
不要只相信一位裁判
把必須信任的東西說到最小
再請好幾位彼此獨立的裁判
公開的互相核對
記得章子蓋在寫下來的那句規格上
而當證明長到沒有人讀得完
我們靠的是機器能檢查的證書
人負責的是把規格寫對
那份collapse假證明騙過了兩位裁判
卻也讓這套系統多了好幾道防線
最後問你一個問題
如果AI教給你一份
長到讀不完的證明
說你的程式沒有錯
你會想先檢查哪一樣東西
留言告訴我
喜歡的話訂閱AI Notebook
開啟通知
我們下次見